three incredible things just happened
one have a look at adobe's Firefly text
to image AI the first version was not
bad it was kind of usable but good news
Firefly 2 is already here and it is so
much better two we can now control text
to image AIS using Rich Text this seems
like a crazy idea so I wonder what this
is for why is this useful and three from
now on we will not only visualize but
even alter the world around us so first
Firefly 2 it can perform text to image
this is where absolute magic happened
look how version two compares to version
one not even close these go from a solid
Improvement to I am not even sure what
is going on here
too my goodness look
now that is a huge leap of capabilities
for macro images I love this one and
just imagine what we will be capable of
just a couple more papers down the line
I have to be honest I can't even imagine
can you also their gallery of results
has also improved Leaps and Bounds and
don't forget this tool is being handed
out to millions and millions of people
all around the world in photo shop and
adobe's other tools dear fellow Scholars
this is 2minute papers with Dr
Caro but sometimes we don't want to
create an entire image sometimes we have
an image that is just right but we would
like to spice it up with an underground
city
waves new clothes or new planets or this
adorable thing in these cases generative
f is going to be excellent now Photoshop
has been used for decades now to put
text with all kinds of options into
designs but here they now introduced
something more exciting text effects
from now on you don't even need to be a
proper artist to create letters made out
of gingerbread yarn woven fabric you
name it they also showcased generative
recol this is for Vector images where
the boundaries of the object are known
exactly from a text description this is
a useful feature but in my opinion this
can be done with traditional techniques
too no AI is required not too impressive
but a useful addition nonetheless this
video is not sponsored by Adobe we do
not have any business ties with them
this is why I can keep saying that this
is good but this is not that impressive
so all in all solid techniques not
necessarily the best text to image on
the market we've seen better but the
overall package is good and it is going
to be put in the hands of millions and
millions of artists now outside of
Photoshop when it comes to text prompt
we have always used plain text but here
is a crazy idea from a really cool paper
so what if we could use Rich Text
effects to make our prompts and as a
result make our images more expressive
sounds great but wait is this really
useful I mean you can add some colorful
letters here to the hair and the hair
gets the appropriate color but we could
do this anyway well if you are not a
Believer check this out we can also use
Font Styles which would then translate
to Artistic Styles H I like it now we
are getting there or if we want to make
just one object pop there we go but
let's go a bit crazier footnotes this
allows us to prescribe more details
about an object without having to
rewrite the whole prompt if we don't
like it we change the footnote and there
we go that's a good one too but let's go
even crazier links we can now link to a
particular image if we wish to get a
particular breed of dog or a particular
particular product for a backpack from
our images and now something really
simple but really Dreadful I mean
powerful you'll see in a moment let's
play with Tex size so would you like
pineapples on your pizza or would you
like pineapples on your pizza you have
to choose one Choose Wisely fellow
Scholars all right you know what being
the good fellow Scholars you are I'll
let you get away with more PE pepperonis
or mushrooms I would absolutely love to
see this in future products not the
pineapple pizza but Tech size so good
and now hold on to your papers fellow
Scholars because three we will now not
only visualize but even alter the world
around us first we capture a few photos
of a real world scene and then create a
virtual copy of it so far so good Nerfs
do that we have seen lots of works on
this already but here step number two
the geometry of the scene is then
estimated and then the lighting is
estimated too and now we create a
virtual object then put it into the
scene and oh my that metal basket will
actually reflect the light in the scene
properly and will cast a beautiful
Shadow too and it works elsewhere too
Reflections and shadows appear as they
should what a wonderful paper and these
objects can also be part of a simulation
in a virtual world that really gets my
mind going this way we could capture a
real world place around us and start
playing with it as if it were a video
game or insert ourselves into a virtual
world train self-driving cars safely
Within a simulation that is a copy of
the real world now for this to be really
useful the quality of the results would
need to improve a bit but the concept is
now out there however this is still an
incredibly potent concept why you fellow
Scholars know very well that one of my
favorite phenomena in research is seem
to real what is that s to real is when
we would like to train a robot for
something in the the real world but when
starting out this little AI is not doing
very well at first it might fail a great
deal before it starts to be competent at
his job take self-driving for example or
even a vacuum cleaning robot now imagine
that we can create a computer simulation
and they would train in this simulation
safely and my other favorite efficiently
you see 1 second in real life is 1
second however with a powerful computer
that same 1 second in real life can be
used to simulate hours or even days of
progress if we wait just a bit we might
get a masterful AI that has trained
essentially for years and years and here
we add a Twist to it what if the virtual
world is based on the real world M we
can scan the real world and create a
simulated video game from it with that
now these AIS are able to train in the
real world yet they do it safely and
efficiently and with this new paper add
another twist we have the real world and
now we can even alter it we can create
scenarios that would normally be almost
impossible in the real world and the AI
will be able to train on it for years
and years I love it and just imagine
what we will be capable of just two more
papers down the line what a time to be
alive experiment tracking model
evaluation and production monitoring for
your deep learning projects and llm apps
this is what weights and biases does and
it is the best everyone is using it try
it out now at wb. me/ paper or click the
link in the description below